here's why you want an affiliate Army if
every month you get Affiliates instead
of customers then every month that
affiliate brings another $100,000 to my
business which means month one I do
100,000 month two I do 200,000 300 400
500,000 and so on and so forth versus me
just trying to sell 10 people every
month that are worth $10,000 I would
Plateau at 100,000 I would never grow
even if I don't increase my Outreach or
increase my advertising the Affiliates
is going to pop off new customers to me
every month so every month I add more
that pop off customers to Me So
eventually I have this Army of
Affiliates that are pushing traffic my
way and you never sold a customer
directly